alors le sénat c'est d'abord une
composante d'un pouvoir c'est-à-dire du
pouvoir législatif ce qui est vrai c'est
que là encore l'idée du bicamérisme
c'est d'avoir deux regards en quelque
sorte sur chacun des textes chacune des
décisions qui est prise par voie
législative et que de ce point de vue là
on a voulu modérée c'est tout souvent
d'ailleurs ce qu'on dit c'est que les
députés sont réputés impétueux peut-être
parce que plus jeune en tout cas
clairement plus politisé et que de
l'autre côté on a une chambre qui est
toujours présenté comme une chambre de
réflexion
ça n'a pas été rappelé tout à l'heure
parce que c'est une évidence c'est aussi
une chambre qui renouveler
progressivement par moitié là nous
raisonnons sur le sénat issu du scrutin
d'hier comme si c'était une élection
comparable à celle des législatives mais
ça n'est que la moitié des sénateurs qui
a été renouvelé et donc c'est vrai que
que politiquement le président du sénat
a qui plus est candidat à sa réélection
effectivement cherche à montrer la
dimension contre-pouvoir est logique
juridiquement constitutionnellement je
dirais que le rôle de modération à
l'intérieur du pouvoir législatif est
plus conforme semble-t-il à l'adn
institutionnel de la vème république